Well,
I can tell,
I can tell you these attempts to shut
people down or being made because you
need to know this,
so as far as I've been able to
determine,
this kind of protest is an expression of
a philosophy that's grounded partly in
postmodernism,
partly in Marxism.
The postmodern element is basically
this.
There is no such genuine individual
identity group identity and you liked it
or not only have the interests of your
group and the whole world is nothing but
a battle ground between groups of
different interests.
There's no dialogue,
there's no possibility of parking
between the groups.
It's just a power stage where combat has
to take place and so the reason that
speakers with whom the radical
postmodernists tend the is to degree or
denied a passport because those people
do not believe from the philosophical
position.
The dialogue can bring consensus and all
that's left if you forgo that particular
principle is,
and this is only where it starts,
you know the fuck is that,
that you're all pretty damn civilized
and thank God for that.
Because if there were enough fools in
the crowd,
especially those who are intent on
violence,
this would turn out very differently.
We do not want to go down that pathway.
It's a big mistake.
We've been down that pathway many,
many times.
I would certainly not conforming to a
consensus that was against my belief
merely because it was a consensus in the
group is wrong.
The question was,
if there was a consensus against my
beliefs,
what are your goals with them?
And answer would be,
well,
first it would depend on what my
conscience said.
What are we going to do?
Assume that the consensus is correct.
The Nazis had a consensus,
right?
The end of it.
Joel has a conscience and you have to
know when the group is made a mistake.
In which case what's the maximum?
Talked a lot in your personality closet,
very confronting your shadow and
generating your shadow.
Um,
do you find that people who care less
about what other people think and care
more about their conscience have
integrated their shadow maybe more than
people who care more about others?
Can you hear me at all?
You got a question,
the question was stabbing from my
personality class are willing to abide
by.
There are those who've been to braided
their shadow and I would say yes,
because you have to be a bit of a
monster to stand up to the crowd,
right?
If you're too concerned with people like
you and if you're to avoid conflict,
then you're going to cave to pressure
and you don't want to do that because if
you let people stop you from moving
forward,
you just end up being something and if
you're someone who's got no life in you
and that's no good for you have to get
tough,
but you have to give tough in a way
that's controlled,
right?
It has to be controlled because
otherwise you're the puppet of your
worst impulses and that's a terrible
thing to be.